A ton of the numbers that we encounter in
daily life are rational numbers since we
can count many things or just can split
them into parts that we can measure, but
there are certain situations that might
not be quite this simple. Let's say that
you have a little cousin and she wants you
to build her a slide. This isn't just any
slide though. Your cousin is very
particular. She wants the slide to be
exactly eight feet high, and she wants it
to go from a trainer backyard, down into
the lake by her house which is 12 feet
away from the tree. Now you need to figure
out how long the slide will be so that you
can buy enough material to make it.
You know that there is a rule for the
right triangles, the Pythagorean Theorem,
that says that the side lengths of a right
triangle, a, b, and c, where c is the
longest side, fit the formula a^2+b^2=c^2.
Since the slide, the tree, and the ground
make a right triangle, with the slide
itself as the longest side, you know that
you can begin to look for the length of
the slide by first taking 8^2+12^2, which
is just 8 times 8 + 12 times 12.
For starters, what is this number? Please
type the number of your answer into the
box right here. Remember to do your
multiplication before your addition.